يستنفد الأشخاص الأجانب
مخزون الطوارئ لديهم ، نعم ، لقد استنفدوا ،
استخدمته كآلية
للتلاعب بالأسواق
بينما كان الغرض العميق هو
التخفيف من النقص في العرض
سواء كان ذلك على النحو الذي يختاره الجميع ،
شكرًا لك
[الموسيقى]
والطاقة المتجددة وتغير المناخ
ومحاولة تخيل أن
الانتقال سيحدث في يوم واحد
أصبح الآن أكثر واقعية وأن
الانتقال في الواقع لن يستغرق
عامًا فقط وليس 10 سنوات وربما 30 عامًا
جيدًا ، فأنا خطة الانتقال الحالية
تطفو
بصراحة إنها لا تقدم
ما  نحتاج إلى خطة انتقالية واقعية مثلى
نراها اليوم إذا
نظرت إلى المكالمة اليوم فهي 8 مليارات طن
وهذا هو الأعلى منذ 2013 8 مليارات
طن
تكلفة استدعاء برميل النفط المكافئ
60 إلى 80 لكن برميل النفط المكافئ لذلك
في الأساس ، نحن ننتقل إلى الفحم ،
فقد كانت تبلغ عشرين دولارًا